في بريطانيا مركب كيميائي شديد السميه
يباع بشكل غير قانوني كحبوب لخساره الوزن
وهو متهم بوفاه 32 شخصا في البلاد
وزير الدوله للامن قال انه سيعيد تصنيف
حبوب انقاص الوزن التي تحتوي على ماده دي
ام بي على انها سم التشريع الجديد الذي
ينظم استخدام الماده سيدخل حيز التنفيذ في
مطلع اكتوبر من العام الجاري القرار كان
في اساسه ناشط وفيت ابنته عام 2017 بسبب
تناولها لهذه الحبوب ويضغط على الحكومه
اليوم منذ ذلك الحين لحظر استخدام الماده
وبمجرد ان تصبح اللوائح ساريه المفعول
سيحضر بيع دي ام بي بشكل قانوني الا من
قبل صيدلي لديه ترخيص عن وزاره الداخليه
المزيد حول سوق حبوب التنحيف حول العالم
مع كيلاميس
تشير ادويه التنحيف الى المكملات الغذائيه
التي تساعد على انقاص الوزن عن طريق منع
امتصاص الدهون او الكربوهيدرات او تقليل
الجوع او تسريع عمليه التمثيل الغذائي
النساء اللواتي تتراوح امارهن بين 18 عاما
والرابعه والثلاثين هم الاكثر استخداما
لادويه انقاص الوزن رغم ذلك لم يؤكد الطب
فعاليه اي منتج تنحيف بنسبه 100%
قدرت قيمه سوق عقاقير انقاص الوزن
العالميه باربعه مليار دولار امريكي في
عام 2022 ومن المتوقع ان تصل الى 39.18
مليار دولار خلال العام الجاري يعاني اكثر
من مليار شخص على مستوى العالم من السمنه
في 2022
والنسبه تتزايد عاما بعد عام مع زياده
الوعيد بالصحه قد تستقيمه السوق العالميه
في 2027 الى
65.16 مليار دولار منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ مسؤوله عن نصيب الاكبر في حصه
السوق الادويات انقاص الوزن العالميه خلال
2022 ومن المتوقع ايضا ان تكون المنطقه
الاسرى نموا في العالم حتى 2027
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الرياض دكتور عائد القحطاني
رئيس الجمعيه السعوديه لطب جراحه السمنه
دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معانا في الصباح
العربي
يسعد صباحكم وصباح المشاهدين اهلا دكتور
عائد طيب دكتور حبوب تخسيس المتداوله في
منطقتنا الى اي مدى هي امنه والى اي مدى
يمكن اعتبارها بالفعل خطيره صحيه
خلينا نقول انه حبوب التخسيس نوعين نوع
مسرح له عالميا من هياته العالميه سواء
الامريكيه والسعوديه او الاخرى ونوع غير
مصرح او نوع يستخدم كبداء العشبيه او
بدائل بما يسمى يباع بدون وصفات طبيه
النوع الاول وهو المسرح هذا امن وود
دراسات موجوده ومنشوره وبالتالي ما في
مشكله بالنسبه له لكن زي ما ذكرته في
التقرير
العلاج او المركب الكيميائي اللي منع في
بريطانيا هو ممنوع مثلا من 1938 لكن للاسف
انه في ادويه تستخدم لفتره معينه وهو اول
علاج يستخدم لانقاص الوزن في بريطانيا وفي
العالم ولكن وقتها اكتشفوا انه بيسبب
مشاكل كبيره جدا على القلب وعلى الجهاز
العصبي وعلى امور اخرى لانه الوفاء
والدوفيات هذا منعه تماما لاستخدامه وضع
انه غير امن لاستخدام البشري لكن ايش
عملوا الناس
الماده نفسها ووضعوها في مركبات اخرى لا
تعد دواء وانما تعد بدائل عشبيه وبدائل
اخرى على في الصيدليات او بدون وصفه وتباع
في الانترنت واستمرت تباع هذه هي الخطوره
فيها وللاسف اننا نرى ناس كثير يجونا مثلا
تجيب علبه بالدائم العنوان هذا اللي
بنشوفه على العلب لا يجب ان ناخذ الا بعد
ما نتاكد من مركباته الموجوده فيه
يعني بالاساس الكل يبحث عن ثوره عن تقنيه
في عالم التنحيف بدون مجهود وبدون توقف عن
الاكل هل تفي حبوب التنحيف بالغرض بالاساس
خلينا نقول بعد تقريركم عن شطيره
ماكدونالدز وعن الرفع الفائده هذا اكيد
لازم يدور على حبوب تخسيس واشياء تنزل
الوزن لكن خلينا نقول انه
اكيد انه لازم تشوفي الان الاشياء مئه في
المئه
مؤثره وحديثا يعني في السنه هذه والسنه
القادمه سنرى ثوره كما ذكرتي بالذات في
الابر يمكن الحبوب نوعا ما انواع قديمه
وفعاليتها ممكن تعطيك خمسه سته كيلو نزول
مو كثير ولكن المشكله ليست في النزول هو
انه اقاربهم يرجعون انما الاخرى هي الابر
الابر الان بدات تنزل الوزن يمكن تنزل لك
15 كيلو او ما شابه ذلك ومصرحه من الهيئات
العالميه
وفي الغالب تقدر تحافظ لفتره معينه يمكن
تحافظ عليها سنه اذا غيرت نمط غذائك
فالناس يحتاجون ايش علشان ينزلوا وزنه
ويحتاجون شيء يساعدهم لنزول الوزن مثل مثل
الرياضه مثل النشاط الغذائي تغيير نمطهم
ثم يحتاجون انهم يغيرون نمط حياه من اجل
المحافظه على هذا النزول ليست المشكله في
النزول في الغالب هي المشكله انك ما تقدر
تحافظ عليه على المدى البعيد طيب دكتور
بالنسبه لاليه عمل هذه العقاقير او هذه
الحبوب للتنحيف هل بالفعل انها تسرع الايض
عمليه الايض وبالتالي حرق الغذاء والتحويل
الى طاقه
الحبوب اللي منعت الان وذكرته في تقريركم
هذه نعم كان العامل الرئيسي انها تعمل
بالضبط زي عمل الغده الدرقيه فتشتغل على
الجهاز الحرق اللي هو نظام الحراره
والميتابوليزم والعياذ وتسرعوا بشكل كبير
فيؤدي الى نزول الوزن لكن للاسف الى الان
لا يوجد اي دواء او حبوب وهذا نصيحتي لكل
الناس اذا جاك واحد قال انا بعطيك حبوب
تسرع عندك الحرق اعرف تماما ان هذه الحبوب
وغير فعاله وغير مصرح فيها لا يوجد دكتور
عائد دكتور رهن دكتور عائد من تجربه شخصيه
يعني تذهب الى الصيدليه وكميه هائله
وشركات وانواع متعدده من حبوب التنحيف
يعني بسال الصيدلاني او الصيدليه مثلا
يعني يقال لي بانه لا فائده منها طب لماذا
يتم انتاجها تصدير المزيد ولماذا تصدق
الناس
بالضبط هم يضعونها تحت منتجات اللي ما
يسمونها بالبدائل الغذائيه
هذا
مكملات يقول لك اوكي انا اعطيك مكملات
والله فادك فادك اوكي لكن الخطوره انه اذا
المكملات في مكملات الهيئه الداخليه مثلا
في الامارات اكيد في هيئه مصرحه في
السعوديه في نهايه الدوله الغذاء السعوديه
في دول اخرى فاذا عندك هيئه في بلدك وهي
مصرحه لهذا المنتج والان الحمد لله
التقنيه الحديثه تقدر بسكانر باسكانر تعرف
تماما ان هذا انه مصرح فيه او لا وتقدر
تشوف المكونات وخلاص تطمن عليه هذا خذه ما
عندك مشكله سواء مكمل او علاج وفي الغالب
هو مكمل اما انك تاخذ شيء مكونات وخاصه من
شرق اسيا مكونات بيقول لك هذا بيخسس هذا
بيحرق الدهون هذا فيك تماما انه داخله
ماده معينه بعضهم تتصوري بيضعون مدير
للبول يعطوك اياه علشان ينزل السوائل من
جسمك بعد سته كيلو ممتاز لكن في الاخير
تنتهي بف الكلوي او ينزل لك مواد سحبت من
الاسواق زي الريداكتيل زمان قبل الخمس
سنوات او عشر سنوات وهذا يزيد الحرق وهذا
ولكن للاسف انه يؤدي الى القلب
والعصب اذا لا تاخذ شيء نعم يعني اعرف ناس
قدموا استقالاتهم اثر غضب بسبب تناول حبوب
تنحيف يعني اثرت على اعصابهم حتى يعني
موجود وسحبت
بالضبط وسحبت من الاسواق لهذا السبب اذا
الناس اذا بيسمعونا الان نتمنى انهم
يفهمونها نقطه انت لا تاخذ اي شيء من اي
سواء خارجيا او داخليا مش مصرح فيه في
الغالب انك حتجد طريقه معينه لتعرف المصرح
او لا واثنين انه ما في شيء اسمه حرق دهون
في المنتجات الموجوده الان الدوائيه سواء
حبوب او ابر او حتى الابر لا تحرق الابر
ايش بتسوي بتقلل شهيتك وبتقلل حركه المعده
لكن اللي يطمنك للابر او للحبوب الموجوده
الان لان في حبوب نوعين الان في شيء يقلل
شهيتك ويقلل حركه المعده هذا حبوب وفي
حبوب اخرى تقلل امتصاص الفات من من
الامعاء كلهم لهم فعاليه جيده وتعطيك
نتيجه بحدود يمكن سته الى عشره كيلو لكن
الاشكاليه انه تحتاج تحافظ عليها اما
الابر لا تعطيك نزول اكثر ولكن ايضا يحتاج
انك تغير نمط حياتك رياتك علشان تحافظ
عليها شكرا جزيل خيارات الاخرى لان الوزن
الاخرى غير الجراحيه وغيرها المهمه
استفدنا منك دكتور عائد القحطاني رئيس
الجمعيه السعوديه للطب والجراحه السمنه
شكرا جزيلا دكتور